okay let's go next to where do we want
to go how about the seven eight one area
code who's calling today from seven
eight one hey Nico so what's going on
I'm a pretty new fan
I've only been watching the show for
about a week alright well you already
got on the phone earlier to this yeah
but um my question was is do you think
ar-fifteens or other lightweight
semi-automatic rifles will ever be
banned or have a buyback in America in
the future
hard to imagine very very hard to
imagine I mean I think that there's
wonder if you could get into like you
kill about why well because so the I
mean two reasons why number one there is
always an argument in the United States
about any restrictions on guns being
anti consta
against the constitutional even though
it's ridiculous I mean of course we have
some little you can't go and buy
shoulder-mounted RPGs or whatever it's
enough to sort of underwater where
people get drawn into sort of semantic
discussions about well what defines an
assault rifle what do you know what are
we talking about when we say
semi-automatic and automatic so I think
that generally the pro-gun right has
done a really good job of muddying the
waters that it would be very difficult
from a practical perspective to do it
but more importantly I just don't think
we there's the political appetite to do
it I think that you know if you can't
even get universal background checks
passed after the Sandy Hook shooting
with 85 percent of the country agreeing
on it how are you gonna ban ar-15s and
do a government funded by back I mean I
just don't see it it's an unfortunate
reality yeah I mean well listen most of
the crime most of the gun homicides are
happening with handguns I know that some
of the some of the bigger yeah right
exactly so there's not I mean we can
still do a lot of good without touching
ar-15 and similar firearms but I'm just
not seeing the political appetite to do
any of it and the NRA is so powerful
and it's it's a wedge issue so I don't
know I'm not optimistic about it that's
a harsh answer but I can agree thank you
the truth though yeah I appreciate the
call thank you so much okay let's go to
a break sorry for everybody I wasn't
able to get to I know a lot of people
are holding but we will take calls again
live streams also an opportunity in the
evenings to get on the phone with me